China is the most polluting country in
the world as well as the largest
consumer of energy
Shirley's that comes as no surprise
well that's exactly why the Asian
superpower plays a key role when it
comes to meeting the objectives of the
Paris agreement which seeks to limit
global warming by a maximum of 2 degrees
Celsius
[Music]
and to achieve this goal decreasing the
use of coal to produce energy is
fundamental the Paris agreement also
stipulates that the combustion of coal
should be eliminated worldwide by the
year 2050
[Music]
while China currently emits 30% of the
world's co2 emissions even though it
only accounts for 20% of all global
manufacturing this means that China is
still very inefficient when it comes to
managing pollution and this has a lot to
do with its huge dependence on coal to
fuel its power plants
[Music]
Cole is a very cheap way of producing
energy and China has massive coal
reserves and although it wasn't too long
ago that these city plans had a clearly
scheduled end date that isn't so clear
anymore
[Music]
it seems that China has sneakily gone
back on the promise that was made
recently by Xi Jingping himself or at
least they've halted progress
[Music]
in this video we're gonna tell you how
and why China has decided to overlook
the pollution problems caused by using
coal and what can be expected as a
result of this decision
[Applause]
[Music]
check out these news stories there any
three is a pot China warns Trump against
abandoning climate change deal years
after freezing new projects China is
back to building coal power plants
surprised well you shouldn't be
Xi Jingping isn't exactly great at
leading by example it's true that some
progress has been made but China's
current relationship with coal is
generating many questions
[Music]
[Applause]
China is still a developing country and
therefore its demands for energy which
is not only driven by industry but also
by its steadily growing middle class is
unstoppable
China literally devours energy the Asian
superpower is still far from reaching
Europe's position where with cleaner
energy and efficiency improvements we
can aim to keep both energy consumption
and co2 emissions of bay meanwhile the
trend in China is quite the opposite
[Music]
in fact despite all the promises and the
government's many plans the country is
not only failing to decrease its coal
based energy production it's actually
increasing it and with that its
emissions will increase as well
yep I'm saying that China's carbon
linked emissions are growing every year
China and call a fateful match there's a
determining fact in China's relationship
with coal these days China simply cannot
and does not want to stop producing
energy from coal
as we explained at the beginning the
great Asian giant has once again
approved the construction of coal thermo
electric plants in at least 11 provinces
we aren't talking about one two or even
ten new plants we're talking about at
least two dozen new plants some of them
huge which will increase China's coal
based energy production by a hundred and
fifty year watts to put that into
perspective that's equivalent to the
coal based energy production of the
entire European Union
[Music]
and it doesn't in there is a buy all
these new plants 40 new coal mines will
be opened in the upcoming years that is
thousands of jobs will be created in
this industry and this will happen
within just a couple of years now hold
on a second does this mean that China
has definitely turned its back on its
commitment to reduce pollution
well no not entirely at least as long as
we're talking in relative terms between
2012 and 2008 II the percentage of coal
based energy in the energy mix dropped
from 60 8.5% to 59 percent this means
that's in just six years China went from
producing more than two-thirds of all
its energy needs from coal to just over
half of it it's still a huge percentage
but it's also a considerable reduction
and that's the statistic that the
government tends to boast about
but of course the fact that China
decreased its coal dependence by 10
percentage points is not really a cause
for celebration in fact does relative
data really matter when we're talking
about pollution why should the mix
distribution matter if carbon emissions
continue to increase think about it for
a moment imagine that China's total
energy production for one year is a
thousand units of energy and a few years
later it rises to 1500 well assume that
the first 700 of those one thousand
units were produced with coal and years
later they were producing about 900 out
of 1500 with coal technically the
percentage of coal in their total energy
production would have decreased but in
reality coal energy production would
have increased by 200 units and when
we're talking about pollution emissions
and the environments what matters are
the absolute figures and that's
precisely what's happening in China
check this out
[Music]
as you can see since 2000 China is
multiplied it's cold based energy
production by five while in the same
period - the United States and the
European Union have reduced their
significantly and yes okay some may
think about Simon if we measure it in
per capita terms then China isn't the
most polluting country well yes you're
absolutely right it's the same issue as
we had when we considered the energy mix
when we talk about pollution
what matters is absolute figures and how
they evolve and as you can see China
isn't only the largest polluter in the
world its emissions are also on the rise
now just a second before we pass a
verdict
what would you say if I told you that
China besides being a world leader in
dirty energy is also the world leader in
clean energy well it may be hard to get
your head around but it's true in
absolute figures China produces more
energy with clean sources than any other
country on the planet
in 2018 they produced 728 gigawatts with
renewable energy 12 percent more than in
2017 but how is this possible why on
earth are they still building coal
plants instead of focusing on new
technology well the truth is that
there's a lot of internal conflict on
the issue because China literally floats
on coal its subsoil is full of this
mineral without coal some regions would
return to absolute poverty overnight
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of workers who make a living
from this sector miners power plant
workers transporters etc therefore the
problem lies in what would happen in
China if the domestic coal market was
eliminated nowadays it's an essential
sector that produces low-cost coal that
can be sold competitively in
international markets
and that's where the big question arises
the key question will China be able to
me to the international community's
deadlines to combat greenhouse gas
emissions will it really be able to kick
its dependence on coal
[Applause]
the Chinese paradigm from ambition to
reality in the case of China things are
a bit more complicated than they seem as
you can see in this country giving up
polluting plants and relying on
renewable energy sources isn't that
simple
but this problem isn't a new one it
started a long time ago in the 1980s as
you all know China experienced a fierce
industrial and economic explosion
obviously all of that went hands in
hands with an equally fierce demand for
energy and being able to meet such a
high demands with so much inter annual
growth is quite complicated energy
production plants take time to build and
go into service however China needed the
energy it was an immediate demand they
could have wait for months or even years
until the plots were ready
that's precisely why the Chinese
government promoted laws that would
allow companies and regional governments
to anticipate demands and propose the
construction of many more coal plants
than necessary in advance of China's
continued explosion because after all
the growing trends in energy demand was
cleared so they were definitely going to
need more energy plants at their
disposal right well relatively recently
in 2014 the central government went one
step further and allowed its provinces
to approve and build power plants
completely independently that is it
decentralized decision-making and this
wasn't a very good idea not if we're
talking about phasing out coal you see
the rulers of China's provinces usually
b-ball trying to step into that national
political sphere they are career
politicians with an eye on reaching high
positions in the central government
that's where the power money and
influence really are but to do so they
have to show certain skills for example
a remarkable management capacity in the
Chinese model
it's the final results that count so
they have to get their province to
develop if possible faster than the
other provinces therefore provincial
governments do everything they can to
support the industrialization of the
regions this industrialization naturally
requires a lot of energy and that means
cold
it all seems like a good recipe for
success as long as we forget about the
environments and the people living there
because pollution in China's cities is a
real problem and of course faced with
such deterioration imagine China's
international imaged amidst the climate
panic the central government realized
its mistake and as we told you at the
beginning of the video reversed the
decision to build a lot of new plants in
however this reversal has now been
reversed again coal plants have once
again been green less partially to try
and stimulate an economy that has slowed
down in recent years in China every time
growth slows down the government spends
billions and billions and all kinds of
projects and that explains the huge
investment in large coal plants and
renewable energy sources mountains have
been covered with solar panels crowns
with wind turbines and it's rivers have
been filled with dams for hydroelectric
production can you imagine how much
money that'll cost well hold on to your
hat out of the 289 billion dollars that
was invested worldwide in renewable
energy in 2018 China invested more than
91 billion dollars as more than 31
percent
knowing this it shouldn't surprise us to
know that some areas in China have been
completely transformed with a 100%
man-made landscape that goes
hand-in-hand with 100% sustainable
energy and thanks to such artificial
landscapes in 2019 China managed these
great numbers China's renewable power
capacity up 9.5 percent year-on-year in
June so if you thought it was impossible
to be dirty and clean at the same time
well you were clearly wrong just look at
China and it's parallel boom in coal
plants and sustainable energy production
an energy mix this if we were a person
would be two-faced to say the least but
back to the big question can China
kicker's coal habits
[Music]
where here's the problem China's demand
for energy is growing so quickly that
despite the enormous investment that the
central government is made renewables
can't replace other more polluting
energy sources as they struggle to cover
the growth in demand and that's
precisely where the Chinese government's
other big bet comes in and that's
nuclear energy China currently has 46
operational reactors and another 11
under construction that's only the
beginning recently the state nuclear
energy Technology Corporation announced
that the country will build at least 60
new nuclear reactors over the next
decade to date 43 have already been
plans approved and have the necessary
financing to be built and that's not all
an additional 136 projects have been
formally proposed to be analyzed this
makes sense because we're talking about
a country where nuclear energy isn't
taboo in fact we can find initiatives as
curious as that of the China general
nuclear power group cgn which even
invited couples to celebrate their
weddings at the daya Bay nuclear power
plant in Shenzhen of course in exchange
they have to post their wedding photos
online
China is betting heavily on nuclear
energy to complement its renewable
energy sources and its importance keep
in mind that with its current hunger for
energy nuclear energy looks like the
only possible option for the Asian giant
if it is to reduce its dependence on
coal anyway
now it's your turn what do you think and
China effectively abandoned coal stop
building plants and start dismantling
them while its industry continues to
grow will China ever shake its image as
an environmentally hostile place and be
seen as an example of clean energy what
do you think of the situation to reverse
the shutdown of the new coal plants
which goes against China's commitments
in the Paris agreement well leave your
answer in the comments below and I
really do hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget we put out brand
new videos every week also please do
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that we're not mine and
as always thank you for watching and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider mediacom
slash podcast see you there
you